autonomous and self-driving vehicles
something I've been talking about for a
long time I'm here to talk about this
with Dave Rubin
you know Dave before we get to the
latest news on this involving Google's
autonomous cars every time I talk about
this I actually get angry feedback from
people saying hey David you're wasting
your time with this autonomous vehicle
stuff it's never going to be a reality
it's it's just something completely out
of make-believe
and I am I honestly shocked that people
aren't seeing all of the signs we have a
driverless truck corridor being proposed
at the same time that we actually have
driverless truck technology the safety
is is just so superior to to actual
drivers do you see the sort of anger
that exists around why are you talking
about this well that's actually
hilarious that that's what your audience
is saying because every time we do a
story about the future whether it's
about robots or technology or artificial
intelligence any of this stuff
I immediately because I'm a big sci-fi
guy I immediately go to Terminator where
the robots turned on us we're fighting
Skynet nuclear holocaust all of that
stuff and everyone always says that to
me you know you always think
everything's gonna go horribly wrong so
that's funny your audience is saying
yeah we're never gonna get these robot
cars and I'm telling my audience that
the robot cars are coming to kill us I
love all of these stories because
they're so much is changing so quickly
you know what I mean I think there's
brief moments in history where things
really really change the way we live we
happen to be in a burst right now
because of the internet because of
Science and Technology that life 10
years ago will barely be recognizable
from like ten years from now yes what is
really this is what futurists like Ray
Kurzweil and many others have described
a sort of acceleration of technological
change and the the latest report on
Google's autonomous cars says Google's
autonomous vehicles have been involved
in 12 accidents since the company began
testing them six years ago over the life
of the program Google has discovered
nearly 2 million miles with its
self-driving cars and in none of the
accidents was the driverless car found
to
at fault every time I read this you see
articles just focusing on the fact that
accidents took place without number one
discussing what the context of the
accident was and number two without
comparing it to what the accident rate
would be for an individual person
driving that number of miles and I think
those are two pieces of data that are
being missed when lots of corporate
media reports on driverless cars and
autonomous vehicle accidents because
this this is these are incredible
numbers Dave obviously I'm not an expert
in Google cars but yeah there's there's
something strange there like we don't
have anything really to compare it to
the idea that none of the accidents were
the fault of the Google cars is sort of
interesting but I think that something
like this you're giving up so much
control I know right now like uber is
really big here in LA and I always
finally I'm just hopping into somebody's
car I know nothing about this person
yeah you can look and say oh well you
know this guy's got four stars or blah
blah blah but you're giving up a certain
amount of control and I think what we
when we start giving that control up to
machines it's it's hugely different and
I think it's gonna take us a long long
time to get okay with the end when
there's an accident that involves one of
these Google cars whether it's the fault
of the Google car or not I think that's
gonna set this thing back tremendously
but I do think it's the future whether
we like it or not yeah and there's sort
of some level of institutional trust
involved right when you're getting into
the uber car there's to some degree you
think that the risk that the four stars
may not really tell you everything you
need to know is outweighed by the
convenience when you get onto a
commercial airplane you are placing a
significant amount of institutional
trust and that the maintenance has been
done the pilots aren't drunk the pilots
aren't suicidal whatever right so I
think that to a certain degree humans
have been have been okay giving that
trust it's just a matter of getting over
the hill so to speak with the technology
yeah I actually suicidal that way
that way when I land whenever I then
it's like well that was a bonus you know
I mean you have to set low expectations
for these things how long do you think
it's gonna take till these things really
are our mainstream mainstream a hundred
percent is hard to say but I think that
there's a very good chance that within
ten years there will be specific either
highways or or transportation routes
where you will see of predominantly
autonomous vehicles it's not going to be
you know it takes a long time to phase
out all of the manual Drive cars that we
have so from a merely economic
standpoint it's going to take a long
time but I think within ten years this
will be much further ahead than a lot of
people think yeah isn't there an
interesting socio-economic part of this
also because I would imagine that only
rich people or you know the higher
people of the economic ladder they're
gonna be able to afford these things and
assuming that these things get you where
you have to go faster and you're on
separate roads that are probably going
to be nicer and newer you're gonna
really start having two levels of people
where the rich people are getting places
faster I guess people are already
getting places faster right but you're
gonna really sort of physically separate
people by economics yeah as if they're
not already separated by so many
elements and then of course the jobs
element which a lot of people say David
this would destroy jobs this would
destroy cab drivers and uber drivers dry
end and those who are driving trucks etc
but to that I say let's look back in
history has there been any instance
where the fear of technology replacing
jobs has ultimately prevented that
technology from from becoming a
mainstream it's never happened yeah I
mean you cannot stop progress that's
just how it is so last thought on this
because I have to take it to the
post-apocalyptic dystopian future
wouldn't then the the real issue is
something like this is again where we
give up so much of our control meaning
our physical control of the car we give
up so much of that to a computer that
really the future terrorism is going to
be in hackers and cyber terror when they
can hack into our system and suddenly
control our cars and have cars crashing
into other cars and driving
Rhodes and Eliza like isn't this just
another layer of us becoming embedded
with something that we don't fully
understand that it will that we don't
fully understand is sort of subjective
but what I would say to that is the
following with every technological
advancement there has been the fear and
ability to misuse or hijack that
technology that's just part of
technological advancement and much like
the job loss argument I don't think that
that alone is ever going to really
justify not moving forward